one-on-one today I am speaking with
Connie Connie I don't know anything
about you yet but I'm excited hey tell
me a little bit about your business and
what you need help with right my name is
Connie do suck i'm from pittsburgh PA
and as I don't know if you can see with
my shirt it's called mama snacks mama
snacks all right good and when I was
pregnant with my first child and being
on to go I needed healthy foods I think
a whole food supplement that has fruits
vegetables and whole grains and they all
work in synergy together so when I would
go out I could never find those three
things together i would get either a
fruit fruit and vegetable or just little
bags of fruits or just junk called
lunchables that I wouldn't eat ever so
then when I was breastfeeding my baby I
refer to it as giving her mama snacks
I'm like all time for Mama snacks
everyone thought does the greatest term
then it just dawned on me like two years
later like put to put all this together
call it mama snaps and have fruits
vegetables and whole grains convenience
on the go now this is for the moms or
this is for the kids this is or anybody
who wants nutritionally girl like you're
eating right now you just need a quick
snack yeah good go to the store and get
mama snaps you would have a fruit and
vegetable whole grain and maybe like a
peanut butter the dip or whatever ok but
so you're targeting moms here this is
for the adults yep it started target
market mothers okay got it got it cool
going on now I'm sorry what's going on
now it's men on hold we've been home
yeah it's driving me nuts i I've done
things with it back in like when I had
Skyler I would make someone give them
out but just stop there just don't have
the money don't have the guidance I just
hurt no Skyler my one of my best friends
has a kid named Skyler like this is
becoming a popular name I've never heard
of it before him but now here's another
Skyler so this is it this is the trend
so what's happening so you started this
thing to two years ago and you thought
it was a great
yeah and what you just weren't able to
pick up traction well it actually I
started 2009 played around with it and
there what I wasn't a social media
person I was in like drill into any of
that I don't even know if I was even on
facebook or any of us so there was none
of that to help me now in class during
those times it was just coming on TV to
start being healthy and nutritious and
now everybody's in it you know it's like
it's not just on TV anymore people are
really being proactive about their
health and when I started I didn't I
think the time is now like timing is
everything I just think right now with
social media with everyone being healthy
I've done researched and people in
magazines are writing and they're
putting together mama snacks that oh
this is what I do for my kids and send
them off the skull but the mother has to
go get this and go get that and go and
put them all together so if it's just
together that's why mcdonald's there's a
line people want convenience and they're
buying lunchables which are terrible for
kids or the aluminum in its just people
write this world just wants convenience
and that's why those little packaging's
for working are you actually selling
this now or you just trying to kick
start the idea up again I just
kick-started all again ok ok exciting
times this is it I like it I like it
Connie on the rides yeah good ok so
what's your next step what do you need
help with I don't even know how much I
need I don't even think it's that much I
think it may be less than five thousand
dollars I need to find the correct
packaging I don't know anything about
food permits or people told me that yeah
you can start everything in your kitchen
you know just locally but you get bigger
bigger you have to be in a different
place with pretty permits in and just
things like that ok so it's it can be
overwhelming
I'd up all the laws and regulations and
and sometimes when you think about
taking something national it's it can be
so scary and crazy that you end up not
doing anything because it's it's too
hard uh-uh but the key here is like get
started do something small just get a
little bit of feedback going on even in
your local community in you said you're
in Pittsburgh Pittsburgh Pittsburgh moms
just start selling to them start working
with people you know friends family you
got to figure out what the magic recipe
is going to be what combination of foods
right you have an idea right now you
have a plan which is great quite often
what we think we're going to do is
different than what we end up doing I
the only way you get that information is
you have the test and so you start
talking to these moms you've already
kind of laid the groundwork a little bit
with the name right people love the name
so you have to start a business around
this but what is the food gonna be how
much you're going to charge what you
know what's the frequency is it every
day every week every month you got to
figure all that out before you roll this
out you know and and it also teacher do
you want to do this business you know it
sounds like a great idea to start but
once you get into it you may find it's
not for you or you want to position it
in a different way you want to change um
so you got to get out there and start
talking to moms and start building this
thing up small scale like don't don't
think about it being such a big project
that you don't do anything because it's
too scary oh right just just start know
what you can take I talk moms or should
I make it presented in moms um you could
do a combination of both you can say
here's what I'm thinking and I have a
plan but when you're first starting out
it's usually not a great idea to go in
with a pitch you weren't asking for help
so here's what I'm thinking about doing
and you can share with your friends
right you have friends who are moms
right now right
yep and they may end up buying from you
or not it doesn't matter you know you
don't have to worry about doing business
with friends and the issues that might
cause but at least get their feedback
people who are your ideal target market
and you can figure that out if it's busy
moms who have X number of kids or people
between this kids with its age range
whatever it is you'll figure out a
market because just to say you target
moms is huge I got too big a market you
want to narrow that down a little bit
more okay have a set kind of criteria
for the ideal type of customer what
start talking your friends and tell them
what your plan is like here's what I'm
thinking to start what do you think
would you buy this how would you change
it around yeah I mean I did that a
couple years ago and everyone's like go
for and I just was a finance like I
guess that's the biggest thing like
finances why need a lot of money to
start this how come why can't you just
start with a few clients do it on your
kitchen and build it up from there yeah
just start small real small you don't
want that mean by most of the best
businesses in America were started
grassroots like no capital they just
went for it yeah that's true you don't
have to think about how you're going to
expand and be able to serve you know
10,000 people start with four and see
what they think like if you can get four
or five people to buy from you on an
ongoing basis and say hey Connie is
awesome Khan is giving us his great
service I love mama snacks and they
start telling their friends that's a
good problem to have yeah there's
nothing wrong with telling people even
as you grow that hey I can't take you on
yet because I have to figure out how to
grow and you keep serving your clients
that you have in a you know the best way
you can but that's a good problem to
have like growth is a great problem to
have yeah oh yeah you got to get this
thing going I've been sit too long now
do I I mean the whole patent thing do I
need any of that I mean obviously
finances again ah you know I saw I'm not
a lawyer I kind of put that up for
but I wouldn't worry so much of it a
patent you don't have you looking you
could have here because you're not
inventing something right it's not your
own brand new product and most of the
times when that happens it's it's uh
people keep it as a trade secret like
coca-cola there's no it's not a patent
okay it's a it's a recipe because the
thing is with a patent you have to
expose it so you have to say how you do
it I'm called the most people keep it as
a trade secret okay so you know how you
make your meals and what goes into each
one I wouldn't worry so much about a
patent on that side it probably doesn't
make sense for your business if you were
a technology company you invented
something new um then maybe but I in
this case I wouldn't worry about it okay
and how should I I mean the story behind
it with the breastfeeding the moments
like people love to hear stuff like that
how should i go about I think I I need
to make that look photo yeah yo people
like to buy from people and if you have
a passionate store as to why you started
this business mothers will will tap in
to that story right so I have I have a
son and I know it was like he's four
years old now and I still rock you know
the time driven is crazy but especially
the first like six months were were just
out of control and so if you tell your
story and something that that mothers
can relate to when fathers can relate to
as well if it's for them or if it's
buying this service for their spouse
people will relate to that store you
don't want to just say here's what we do
you want to have you on their bare
minimum your face like a nice picture
ideally with your with your son Skyler
and did you have to I Abby's ecology
girl hunters the boy but no host how
does a girl okay my friend Skylar's the
boys boy anyway okay so Skylar hunter
you know you have both of them in there
with you in the picture and you tell
your story like
a couple paragraphs why you started this
business you know what the what the main
reason was how you're using it if you
become a little more brave you could do
a video you know we're doing video here
this is your first time using that
google hangout platform it's great it
doesn't have to be super professional
you know as long as it's it's it's from
the heart and people can feel that
they'll tap into it okay the only thing
i'd recommend and maybe you can watch a
few videos of people who've done you
know their intros simple things like
lighting most basic thing like even as
we're sitting here now you have a light
behind you it makes you appear kind of
dark on the screen love better there so
already I can see you better write it
doesn't matter for this I mean it's
great to see you better but when you're
making your video right I mean you want
to have it ideal even against a flat
background so even if just move over a
couple inches to your left or right so
there's nothing behind you I don't think
like that but most important part is not
the production quality it's you telling
your story very passionately why you
started this business what you hope to
accomplish and then what your product is
all about okay people will tap into that
they'll relate to that and hopefully you
know want to want to buy your product
but I think it's a start it's still
going to be your friends your network
maybe not your direct friends you know
but people in your network if you're
part of any you know Mom groups or if
your kids are going to soccer or part of
a church group any of that kind of stuff
anything in your community that you're a
part of those people will be your first
customers and your your your beta users
your trial users get them on board even
if you're selling it a cost to start
like you're not making money from it
you're investing your time and they're
paying for your supplies yours to get
the feedback like do they like this
thing is this something that they're
going to order on going from you okay if
they're raving about you and they love
it then you can expand and they will
absolutely
you feedback on what to do to make it
better others do like to give you yeah
and mothers like the support of the
mothers to its it's amazing how you know
there's like the competitive thing
comparing their kids to each other but
then there's also a supportive thing
where you want to see each other they'll
do well so um I think is a great it's a
great group to connect with and you
being in it and you understanding it is
a start like a lot of the most
successful business in America were
started by people who have their own
problem they solved it for themselves
and then they went out and helped other
people who are exactly like them okay
yeah you like to be on to the next big
thing that's exciting exciting which I
make some action right that's it the
action oh my dream would be to be in
whole foods so like should I start
eventually that go organic route but i
miss our conventional so it depends on
what your model is going to be because
if your model is delivery so somebody
orders from you they order a care pack
once a week or once a month at last of
the month that model may not lend itself
well to whole foods like with a whole
food supermarket type of environment you
need to have your own product so is that
what you're making are you making your
own set meal that you know people can
buy off the shelf or are you just going
to be combining like you're going to go
to Whole Foods or go to movies place a
little cheaper get get your supplies and
yeah off the people ya know it would be
my own because like if you go to a
convenience store or grocery store right
now you can get little package things
but it's just fruit or vegetable this
would free special whole grains and it
would be just mama snacks okay a moment
like you could go sort pick it off the
shelf and I wanted like enough that you
could throw it in your gym bag your
purse yeah the target market is the
mothers but the mothers by for everybody
so like they throw it in a dad gym bag
so after your workout you snack on so
this isn't going to be a delivery
service where ever
week to get a care package for the week
you want something that's packaged
prepared ready to go you know maybe is
it going to be something like
refrigerator that guys have his fresh
ingredients what's a pull out of the
fridge it's sealed you open it up and
you have everything you need in that
pack that's the idea lunchable but a
healthier version right there I mean I
can physically deliver to local people
right there's different models that I
guess that's a model that I've seen a
lot of recently where people that they
have businesses but they send you
prepared foods either it's just dinner
you know every week or dinner and lunch
whatever it is but it's more of a care
pack then something prepared that you
kind of slide off the lid and ready to
go um it's a great it's a great idea
it's a great vision to be in whole foods
or to be in in something even bigger get
large distribution you need to have
momentum before you get there like Whole
Foods is not gonna take you on right now
oh no eniola and that's fine no it's
great like it's it's great to have a big
vision right it's awesome you have to
keep that in mind you have to you have
to at the same time keep the big vision
but then also take the small steps they
even bigger vision like I've thought
about and it drives me nuts like going
still I want the healthy snacks I have
two kids you know how it is to get one
child out of a car seat it's an ordeal
so it's like it takes more time to get
kids out of a car seat than it is
running a soaring it what you want so
you see all these mothers in line at
McDonald's Burger King everywhere buying
whatever they can yeah junk no healthy
drive-thru anywhere later mama snack
shack would be the ID all the big aha so
like you drive through and the only
thing you can get is healthy foods and
Momo snacks would be there okay so
that's the grand scheme it's good hey I
like it I like it ah and the retail
model could work and you know what the
way to get that started it's not to go
out and open up your own location
because that's going to cost you crazy
money but to partner up with somebody
who's already
doing it so find you know you're going
to go to McDonald's but you find a local
store that that serves your market and
it could be of food Peppa store or it
could be a baby store you know something
just has nothing to do with food but
targets your your target market ok you
can either have a permanent little
displayed there or you can come in for a
weekend or a couple weekends out of the
month and do a promotion and help drive
people to their store as well from the
people in your network and what it does
it helps you test out the model like
does having a physical location work is
that the way you're going to go or
you're going to go just make the product
and do distribution to ideally whole
foods or whoever it is right I mean I
even like like I said this is the big
scheme of things but my friend in
Florida said she's she said this not
even say anything if she is I wish there
was a drive-thru health health store
mm-hmm there is McDonalds there's
nothing and I mean like I said I gotta
start small but that is the big thing so
yeah and you can't let the you-know-what
with with any businesses a million
different big picture options hmm it's
great to have those goals but there's
tons of options and you can't let those
things keep your back from actually
doing something yeah well what's my
problem you don't even know me but I'm
gonna ask you what is my problem ok I
trigger it's good you're a dreamer I
have subscriptions to ink I read and
read and read like I have the
entrepreneur I've been another court
America they keep kicking me out it's
just I'm not meant to do this I'm not
waiting tables I'm fantastic at it
because I have the personality people
are drawn to me what is holding me back
from doing this and I don't fear anymore
I don't know what it is I think your
problem here is you need to in your mind
have it all planned out before you do
anything yeah that's probably it and
there's so many ways you can go that you
don't know what plan to start with and
now it's been two years of nothing
happening and you see opportunities
around you and this
lots of big picture plans but you just
got to get started and if you know what
it rarely works out as you think it will
how much like the best plan you have in
the world is great to start with I'm not
saying start with no plan that's not the
solution but your plan will change and
as you start this thing as you start
seeing some success you'll get pulled in
different directions that you never
anticipated okay I mean like I know
you're beyond video chat whatever car my
daughter like what no way so like I
don't know where you know what I mean
things just like this example being
pulled in this direction I am that no
cloak yeah and it'll it'll kick it will
keep happening I am serendipity I guess
so but you gotta you gotta do something
you got to get started you gotta do
something small everyday to move that
business forward okay so where are mean
like packaging legal should I just go to
local and just get a few to start with
or you know I mean to start yeah like
try not to spend money mm-hmm on your
own even if you're just delivering
things in tupperware to get people
started I can't figure what the recipe
is is going to work for people what's
the ideal mix and you don't want to have
a million options that's gonna kill you
yeah I had but the one that everyone
likes is sliced apples carrots peanut
butter like the dip in a like a whole
grain cracker people write another so
that's like a snack that's not a meal no
it is called mama snack so yes healthy
snacks yeah like between meals yeah so
go go get it um you don't need fancy
packaging don't worry about your having
a logo and branding and all of that
stuff that adds cost at the beginning
you can get disposable containers and
are divided alright that don't take up a
lot of space that is the ideal fit for
what you're doing with your apples and
all that stuff get those are cheap okay
and and start filling them up and and if
you're selling them at
at a retail store or at you know soccer
practices or just deliberate the people
to start let that get started see what
the feedback is ok that making money
from this then you have a little bit of
capital to invest in hey I need a logo
you know I need I need maybe the next
step is just putting stickers on your
packaging with your logo on it you don't
need to go and spend fifty thousand
dollars on everything you need to get
started you think I like make a flyer
and get that out and wait til people
contact me then do it I wouldn't you
know wait for people to contact you is
never the answer you out there talking
to people and you have a fire that's
great that helps but it's going to be
you talking to people I'm not selling
them saying hey you need to sign up for
this you know it's the best thing ever
but just getting your feedback seems to
be willing to try it out test it out
even a break-even cost for you you know
not factoring your time in but just
paying for your materials o wise and see
like if so people like to talk mother's
love to talk right mother's love to talk
I get home when I get here all these
stories about who's doing what and it's
like ah yes the talk if you get a great
product in the hands of mothers and they
love it they're gonna tell each other
that's true and it's not gonna matter
about your logo in your brain you know
all that stuff that stuff will come
later and help you expand and go
national right and get into the whole
foods and all that but you just need to
have a great product and a great
delivery mechanism if somebody can
easily come by and pick up your product
if it's from your house or if it's from
a store of somebody that you know where
bebe store that offers to have a little
fridge for you to store your stuff in
there yeah just need to get it started
okay just like you said kick start it
again yeah but this time you got to make
it happen yeah because I'm just I'm so
it's hard to spend in the wheels are
going there I'm just over it yeah people
doing things and I'm like
really don't half the brain i do like
what is my problem it's just they're
doing it they're doing it that's the
difference you know why honestly
sometimes the smartest people are the
worst at getting started because you
have to figure it out where it's like be
dumb just do something I brought them
back to the kingdom come yeah pick up
there's your advice be dum dee-dum
dee-dum and do it absolutely not like
like you go we all injustice you don't
like get 10 people using this at cost
figure out that is your first plane 10
people add costs using you're using your
your system and you see if we will come
back you think that point like how I saw
this per one or like a week and delivery
system or what they need like talk to
them how would this work for you that's
what you asked so you go up to the moms
who you know think about from your own
experience it's nobody came to you and
told you this idea what would you want
to see that's that's how you're starting
this whole thing but then from there ask
them what they need do you do they want
you to deliver it are they willing to
come pick it up can you have it at a
convenient location for them to get at
all that stuff build it off of their
feedback huh but 10 people who can use
your product at cost and will become
repeat buyers don't want them just to
buy one thing once you want this like
weekly purchases because they love it
and so what do you have to do to get
your product to that level what do you
need to add in like if someone stops
buying from you ask them why I feel like
I want honest feedback I'm willing to
take like anything you can give me tell
me you know why this didn't work for you
okay do you need something else inside
like are the apples no good is your
whatever like get their feedback if you
can get it to 10 people who are repeat
buyers from you that alone is going to
help kick start your business because
they're going to tell their friends it's
impossible to have somebody but
things every week from you and for them
not to go out when they're having a
coffee what you know stroller walking
with their friends and not say hey I'm
i'm using the service it's great people
come to you i know i mean just well like
when you go to a restaurant it's great
you tell your people put on facebook or
whatever is yeah it's just nature of the
beast of the more I'm especially around
Mother's it's crazy the amount of demand
chatter is out of control it is I'm
telling you I'm like man I can't deal
with it Oh fox sports drink beer so I
don't we want them talking about you
mama snacks okay all right Andy said
start with mom groups or just like my
start small man cuz I'm on this sounds
horrible but I'm not a member of mom
groups because they drive me nuts okay I
mean that may be something that over
time you you want to become the
spokesperson for your company so you're
gonna have to be out there talking to
people but you don't have been heavy
marketing mojet cuz you don't really
even know what you're selling yet you
have to still finalize a product and the
mechanism and all that so start with
start with your friends start with
people you know who are moms and maybe
they know somebody who could use it to
ok I'm getting this start it's gonna
cost X amount of dollars per thing this
is just covering my costs not my time
I'm looking for 10 people to start this
with and get feedback on ok but with
your friends you can also think about
any groups like it doesn't mean mom
groups but any clubs that you're your
kids may be a part of any school groups
any church groups any anywhere you
volunteer you know your your husband is
part of any groups where he works any of
that stuff you don't they don't need to
be the closest friends to you often it's
the people on the on the outside of your
network who will do this like I would
test it for you if you ship to toronto
canada i will test it for you but it's
probably too far you just have to tell
people your story and what you're trying
to do like people want to help
right that's true and my daughter's just
going to kindergarten this year so I'll
be more active yeah so Scylla is older
than hunter yeah okay temper and Hunter
just turn to okay great never max and
you say mama snack he knows exactly what
it is he just served sir so that's your
Start then people don't worry about
planning everything out just get 10
people paying you for what you do okay
get their feedback is that is that as
simple enough next step I just need
someone to tell me me you already know
you gotta you can do this this isn't
like there's a lot of people who aren't
workers who just have this crazy dream
of doing something but you know like
they're never gonna make it right you
could do it I think you're a worker I
think you can pull this off we just
actually have to get started you gotta
start putting some momentum into it okay
I appreciate that it means a lot thank
you so yeah all right I feel good cool
all right well um keep me posted maybe
we do one of these again sometime soon
all right I appreciate it this is all
what's your step for the next week what
you gonna do next week what do I ended I
have to you know I have to find
packaging right I need some packaging
hmm simple packaging I'll get a flier
made i will contact um 10 10 friends or
not I'll do 20 friends because and like
close friends and ten outside my bird I
mean like you know just mom
acquaintances I know good and ask for
their friends too okay you don't try to
join and and if they have any friends
who would join too and say this is a
test market I need I'm doing this test
market here's my product give me
feedback what do you think yeah I'm even
before making a fire like you don't need
what are you gonna put on your fire you
don't even know what you're doing yet
well you said to put like our pictures
and my story
yeah so that's later that's when you got
you into marketing mode yeah I'm all
like you should be able to get people to
to sign up a few people just by talking
to them what I for the buying is per
week that's what like weren't word I go
from here yeah you want to get 10 people
on board for buying it from you every
week uncle find one a week you want some
repeat purchases okay and the people who
drop off like maybe they buy one and
that's it like that's you got to talk to
them not not to convince him to come
back but what happened what can I do to
be better all right I don't care if you
ever buy from me again but I just want
to know how to make my product better
right and people understand you're in
that position then they'll be supportive
don't you come in and you say this is
the greatest thing ever you're gonna
love this you have to try it out then
people are put on the defensive and they
don't like to be sold to right did you
come and say hey I have this great idea
I think it could really helpful it was
helpful for me i'm not sure if it'll
work for you or not but I'd love to test
it out and get your feedback on it you
know help out a local mom entrepreneur
people love that stuff you know did be
happy to support like I've said one of
your friends came and asked you that
you'd help them right you you would give
them feedback and help them out along
the process so you got to be willing to
get out there and do it yourself too yes
sure okay all right I see lots of
notetaking there that's good bad time
for some action okay all right kini
posted him happy to help anytime it's
been great chatting with you and good
luck thank you thank all right thanks
Connie Cheers
you